let's bring in the cast of Star Trek
beyond Simon Pegg Zoe Saldana Chris Pine
Zachary Quinto John Cho and Karl Urban
the purchase yours
okay the first question just to kick
things off is obviously this is a very
big year it's the 50th anniversary of
Star Trek so for all of you to have sort
of the challenge to make a movie that a
is going to honor the 50th anniversary
of Star Trek be I be the next level in
this trilogy of films and C also be just
a great action movie for people who are
not fans or have never even seen a Star
Trek movie before let's start Seiden
yeah that was very important to us Doug
Jong and I going in and Justin we wanted
to sort of try and create a hybrid of an
episode of the original series with you
know a spectacular cinematic event these
films the Star Trek movies have always
been event films with a TV series you
get time to to spend with the characters
it's a longer game with the film you
kind of have to hit it has to be very
self-contained it has to be memorable
and and so that was the the thing was to
try and make sure everybody that's been
here for 50 years gets what they deserve
in terms of a good Star Trek film but
the people who've never seen it before
who perhaps aren't as familiar with Star
Trek they don't know about Kirk fighting
whatever you said Scott you know then
they they're welcome to this is an
inclusive universe in every way not just
fictionally but factually thank you I'll
see you know you really shake things up
in this one you know the dynamic the
Kirk Spock dynamic has been explored
twice before already but now definitely
going back to the old show you have
Spock and McCoy together a lot and what
is a good film like with great drama so
how was it for Zack and Carl to really
spend a lot more time together and
further explore that dynamic of these
great characters yeah for me I feel like
this
is probably the most fun that I've had
making a Star Trek film I think what
Simon and Doug were able to do was
present probably the most well defined
well-rounded version of the character
and it certainly gave me a lot of
material to work with and I had an
amazing time working with Zach and I
have a huge amount of respect for him
and his approach and it was just great
to have those two characters that are so
diametrically opposed to each other be
forced into a situation where they have
to depend on each other to survive and
through the process come to a deeper
understanding of who they both are and
it was obviously a great opportunity to
explore a lot of comedy but then to also
really kind of deepen the relationship
between the two and and I think that by
the end of it they were able to go back
to the respective corners with a bit of
inside knowledge and I think that it's
for long-term fans a rewarding
interaction that well I couldn't agree
more Scott Carl took all the words right
out of my mouth literally I gave all
those exact same answers and I had a
great time working together you know in
a movie franchise where we're used to
spending so much time together all of us
really on the bridge of the enterprise
and in many of our adventures it was
actually really nice to have so many
days where it was only Carl and me
together and I think we got to know each
other and appreciate each other already
more more than we already did which was
already a significant amount and yeah
and I think from a character standpoint
I really echo the idea that these two
characters historically and this
franchise are come come at things from
entirely different perspectives and
points of view and I think there's
nothing more fun for fans of the
original show to see that dynamic
unmitigated by Kirk who usually manages
to get between them and
yeah and I think in the same way you
know bones really saved Spock's life in
this film and I think I think there's a
deep appreciation for that obviously and
and and they end this film in a much
better place as a duo than I would say
they begin it
another thing that sort of is a
throwback to the original show instead
dynamic between McCoy and Kirk in the
beginning of the film Chris you had that
scene at the bar where you're
contemplating what's it all mean I mean
it was right out of a scene from the
korbinite maneuver or balance of terror
so what was like to just explore not be
put out in space or that the crew the
enterprise come on you got the right
model I could be in the next film's go
fine you're in G I was gonna get it
Monday it's a sort explore not that the
enterprise has been out in space for 966
days almost three years did you get that
reference nine six six I got it yeah yes
9th September 1966 that's very good
did you deduce that on your own
seriously nine six six I got that you
literally got nine six exact let's go
back to talking to I know
Tata's contract moment but it's like the
limits of my my they just are always
exceeded like I just I think you can't
get any nerdier well what's that moment
when Spock is is a ailing it was like
that scene of bread and circuses where
McCoy says I know why you're not afraid
to die you're more afraid of living I
mean come on
I'm your guy here you are but that row
is to Kirk and McCoy let's talk about
Christi like where where is Kirk three
years into this mission Amy's night
super excited about being a starship
captain uh yeah I always have the most
fun in these films or rather when we're
laughing or talking and then usually
then ship blows up and then we have to
do the ship lowing up acting which is I
think I spent a majority of the film
saying let's go
can we do it I don't know breathing
heavily so that scene in particular was
one of my was one of my favorites and I
talked a lot with Simon about how to
nuance the or what particularly was
Kirk's trip and this whole thing and
once we landed on the idea of him
growing out of we're moving out of
underneath his father's shadow that made
a lot of sense and to do with with Carl
was great fun and we had all that fun
stuff with the whiskey and the vodka
moment which you know just like these
just little itty bitty things that make
us giggle and have a good time that
hopefully people appreciated as you said
it's all these little nuanced beats of
the references or gods that was
improvised by the way when they were
talking about I thought he'd be a vodka
guy that all came out from those guys on
the day and that's the kind of superb
actors we get to work with as writers
it's like sometimes you just go go with
it and they do and they come up with the
best lines no we're still trying to work
hey why'd you start yes as a fan of
beastie boys thank you that the sabotage
ultimately beat the aliens I might be
alone in this but I want to assignment
in your discussion with Justin and Doug
your decision including the including
these classical music as well instead it
was it was a we just loved the idea of
them foiling a technologically
terrifying threat with something very
analog and old VHF you know it was like
radio the the the initial idea was that
they fired an old radio into the middle
of the swarm it took many shapes as we
wrote it but we realized that was no
sound in space we have to abide by
physics some of the time so it was just
the idea that you know we like the idea
that Jayla had discovered this old ship
that had an archive of music she
discovered rap music and liked it you
know she says she likes the beats and
shouting and and we like the fact that
in the end they use it to kind of you
know cause the swarm to have this big
and I like the fact they all have the
idea together about what what it could
do and you know the sabotage was a song
we used in o.9 and it is part of Kirk's
childhood it all links all these things
links back to his past and his dad
the motorbike the song it's all kind of
him letting go of these these things you
know and moving on as a man as well so
it's important for Kurt's character but
it's just a kick-ass song you know I
mean if anything's gonna blow up a swarm
of spaceships it's gonna be the Beastie
Boys come on Scott whoever the film has
such a lovely tribute to Leonard Nimoy
and I'm curious was there initial
expectation earlier on in the process
that he would be part of the film before
his passing and how did you figure out
how you wanted to pay homage to him if
Leonard was well enough to be a part of
this film I'm sure he would have been
and I know that there were early
conversations with him about that
possibility which you know true to his
incredible self he knew himself well
enough to know that that wouldn't be
possible at a certain point and and then
I think it became important to all of us
to figure a way to honor his legacy and
I thought Simon and Doug did a beautiful
job of incorporating it into the
narrative at the film we all carried him
with us through this production for sure
and it was definitely a different kind
of feeling to make this movie without
him for me in particular but I think he
was very much a part of it in spirit and
certainly in the film now and and will
be a part of anything we do moving
forward for sure we wanted to make it
part of Spock's
are exact Spock's Ark as well not just a
reference to two-spot prime or you know
what we did eventually which of course
which was to dedicate the film to him
but we wanted to have his passing be
something which inspired our Spock to
move on as well and so it became an
integral part of the story not just to
kind of nod in lenez direction that felt
more right to do it that way my question
is for mr. Simon I heard the director
say that the main reason he wanted to
tackle this project is because his
childhood dream sort of was to blow up
the enterprise and then bring it back
together so I'm wondering was that a
collaborative effort or was that all his
idea that he presented to you and then
you guys developed it in the script I
hated the idea at first we had litter I
swear we had like rise about it like I
was shouting down at him down the phone
we can't do that you can't destroy the
enterprise my
my problem was that we've if you think
it's something new then we've seen it
before it happened in search for Spock
it happened in generations but Justin
was like very very determined and as we
spoke about it I realized what he was
doing brilliantly was he was not only
sort of taking out a main character but
he was removing the physical connective
tissue between the crew to see what
happens when you take away the thing
that physically bonds them together you
know if you take away that thing that
necessitates there being a unit do they
dissipate or do they come back together
and that was the genius of that thing
you take it away very violently and and
dramatically and then you wait and see
if they all come back together to be
this family which is essentially what
they are and and of course they do and I
realized I back down immediately and
said yeah you're right which I do
occasionally do that not always but in
this instance I realized it was a
brilliant idea and but yeah in Italy I
was opposed to it a little bit about the
evolution of your character and also her
feelings for Spock in this movie um
she's tired
I think she's homesick and I felt that
that's the one thing I appreciated the
most about what Simon and Doug that did
for for this installment is that they
they made us they made us human you know
and and and just homesick and sad and
and and how being overly worked and
being away from home and all the things
that keep you grounded can put a strain
not just on the intimate relationships
that you may have but also you know the
professional ones and I thought I would
never see the day where I can I would
see like I would walk into the
enterprise and we're kind of like not
rolling our eyes at each other but we're
not that you know excited to see each
other and so and and I thought okay well
this this is a great place to start
because I can only imagine where we're
gonna end up lights like and we
literally end up in in the opposite
direction we're dying to be close to
each other we're dying to save each
other and be get back together so I
thought okay that's brilliant and you
know she's um I guess the relationship
with Spock and and ahora felt so
normal and human to me that it's sort of
the consequences that that may occur
when you decide to love your coworker in
in a you know in a lovey-dovey way and
you know just sometimes the
professionalism can get in the way of
this bridge reality and I feel like
that's what happened between both of
them and I do have a feeling it was
probably like her decision to sort of go
this and you have a lot of stuff that's
about to start brewing and from your end
and I have to figure some stuff out so
it's probably just what was your
decision
be a gentleman think what you need to I
think it ends on a really hopeful note
done here yeah let's go with hope but I
mean but if if he were to walk in with
some other Vulcan girl or I [ __ ] will go
down you know that book I amulet would
come right off contribute to this but it
is 50 years I was in Star Trek began it
seems your character especially has gone
through changes that sort of mirror
woman's changes perhaps in science
fiction in in our culture and society
can you talk a little bit about how you
think she's evolved to what you're doing
now I think there's there's a beautiful
I hate using the word sprouting but it's
true women are becoming very very
independent not just not just to add in
the workforce but also in their personal
lives there's something about like
realizing that you should want to be a
part of something you don't necessarily
have to be a part of something in order
for you to be validated or or respected
or appreciate or considered strong
enough so I feel that that this breakup
that Ahura and Spock have is is amazing
because she fell in love with her
teacher
so he came and as this figure that
represented responsibility and safety
and you know and maturity and wisdom and
now I think that she feels strong enough
to I mean if I choose to see it that way
there is a parallel universe situation
here that's going on with the [ __ ] and
women these days is that there's no
longer this animosity or this resentment
to sort of prove who you are you just
want to be alone you just want to be
left alone to sort of find out who you
are because you're interested in it
you're curious so I like this autonomy
that's happening with women right now
where there's um it's and I like when
when when a battle is fought just with a
spoken word nothing that feels tense or
you know violent behavior or something I
guess you know one of the questions that
we were asked may be you know for
giggles on the on the tour in either
Sydney or London was which timeline
would you choose to be in the original
series or ours if you had the choice and
I did say ours if forced to choose for
this reason like there Roddenberry did
set up a world you know that was
incredibly progressive but it was
tempered by the the social mores of the
era and I feel like we can go further in
in 2016 then he was able to do at the
time and to your point I feel like that
this our version is able to give more to
the women of the people of color in the
cast then then then Roddenberry was
originally able to I think and not
because he didn't want to either because
he didn't want to correct yeah yeah he
absolutely wanted to yeah well let's
talk about let's go a little further
with that John on how Sulu has he filed
and and I'm really like when that idea
came up on how to really get more
background into sooloos character the
idea came up a belief Simon pitched it
and then I was told of it through justin
early pretty early on and when he had
set up at a paramount and we went in to
have a chat and get reacquainted and I
thought it was a beautiful idea
I had concerns about how it would be
received by George I had some other
concerns but it was really the handling
of it that was most important to me and
having seen the film I think it's
nonchalant posture toward it is a the
best thing about it and the fact that
it's normalized and it comes it's kind
of news now but if you rewatch the movie
in 10 years you won't think anything of
it it'll just go right by you
and that's the best thing about it
there's no music cue there's no close-up
it's just I like the one thing that I
guess has has taken a secondary position
is that it wasn't just that we revealed
that he's gay we revealed that he's a
father so none of the none of our
characters have a families that we've
ever talked about so I feel quite
puzzled that in 2016 we're we're having
like it a bit of a fit over who he who
he fathered a baby with the point is
that he's a dad you know he had somebody
on York turn what the point of mine is
he's a rescuer somebody we care about in
York turn so when York town was under
threat that yeah made the threat
tangible we knew that Sulu's family was
there so it may it wasn't just a bunch
of faceless Federation people there was
somebody there that we cared about too
because we care about Sulu and and that
was really important thing the nature of
that relationship wasn't wasn't an issue
and by the way the whole thing with
George's you know people like to make
things into a spat George and I email
all the time big long lovely discussions
about it and and were on great terms it
was never a kind of a we were never shot
each anything like that it was just and
it's a great discussion to have so I'm
really happy with the way that it's been
talked about and responded to and
and I'm still a huge fan of GT for sure
right here this film is a bit
bittersweet with the loss of Anton and
Chris and John have spent quite a bit of
screen time with them what was it this
process working with him and if anybody
on the cast has heard from his family
and their reaction to this film first of
all it's devastating to lose a family
member and you know we're at a point
where we should be celebrating not only
this film but this beautiful man this
talented man and for all of us it is
almost incomprehensible to be at the
point where we have to talk about him in
the past in the pain of his loss is
still very raw
we the wind spent time with Anton's
family and we we know that they will be
very very proud of his contribution the
film and this film will forever be
probably the most special experience for
all of us for you know it represents a
golden period where our family was
together fully together for the last
time and it really was I think as Simon
said the best summer of our adult lives
and we love him so much we miss them
terribly you know the original series in
episodes like who mourns for a torn eyes
gamesters of Triskelion spectre of the
gun Kirk this is a bit right right this
is a bit this is actually a follow-up
because he's heartless like a
father-figure hmm to check off and in
this movie Chris you got to spend a lot
of time with the Anton so like what your
opinion just made him like a really
special actor he was just a good music a
guy he's just a good music a guy he's
very sweet
beautifully authentically Anton there's
not much of a sensor on the boy and I
remember one of the first times I met
him like nine years ago or whatever use
17 and
I invited them back to my trailer to
play guitar cuz I need to play guitar
and he played guitar really really
really well and he said I can't man I
got to go back to my trailer and I was
like okay why and he was translating a
wasn't like he was translating a like an
esoteric Russian novel into English just
because that's what he wanted to do and
eight nine years later I talked to her
and he was still translating it was
still reading this book on physics that
this French philosopher had written and
he still tried to get all his to go to
these please like be in Vancouver and he
wanted to see some German neo
expressionist film that none of us and
he would talk about as if everyone has
or should have seen it well my husband
was the only one that called him he's
like hey are we gonna go see this movies
I call I fell asleep I end up going that
night yeah yeah he's a great guy he was
just totally fearless and I think I
wouldn't you know you try to grasp onto
something that's a positive out of
losing such a um such a good guy and I
think it's just be fearless creatively
he was always working on stuff he had
music projects and photography project
he was going to direct his first film
this summer he was just spectacularly
interested in life in a really great way
so he's got the next question um yeah
this is for Simon what would Tim from
Space Flight and dislike about this
movie well I
this is for those of you who don't know
I started an estate coming to UK called
space and it was about a nerdy guy I
don't know I was talking about it wasn't
me at all but there's a line in space
too where Tim says as sure as eggs is
eggs as sure as day follows night as
Shores every odd-numbered Star Trek
movie is [ __ ] and I wrote that in 1998 I
think and then here we are in 2016 and
I've written an odd-numbered Star Trek
movie and I'm happy to say that Tim is
wrong I
it's an incredible thing to look back on
the circularity of that you know having
grown up a fan of Star Trek and science
fiction to be now participating in such
in it in such an active way I tried to
just make the kind of Star Trek movie
Tim Beasley would like you know that's
what Doug and I did and when I say to
him busily I'm talking about the people
that have been with Star Trek for a long
time you know because Star Trek must
have been doing something right because
it's around for 50 years and if I ain't
broke
you know don't fix it so we we wanted to
embody the original show instill it with
what made the original show great but
also frame it in a big movie way you
know which is a luxury they never had
back in the day that's why that series
turned into such a great thing they
necessity was the mother of invention
would that show they had to make these
wonderful little telly plays they
couldn't rely on special effects now we
can do both and it felt like you know I
was always thinking what would Tim
bisley think front row right here I the
film felt like a throwback to the TV
shows where they go on alien planets and
fight so what was it like for all of you
being away from the con and in space and
actually on a foreign land fighting
enemies I like being on the ship it's
easier no you can understand we were
liking a query and it was just just
everywhere and
helicopters flying really low and I just
I don't know I like and I like bling on
the enterprise it's cleaner the spirit
of exploration on the upside it was on
the upside it was cool to be paired off
though even even though you were having
a miserable time how much I was
complaining but I was so happy that I
was complaining with you to get
fractured off you just it you know
typically your as characters relating on
the bridge
everyone's relating to Kirk you know and
and so there's less talking to one
another and so just getting that
opportunity brought out some different
colors and vibes so it was good dog and
I realized a couple of times I had had
you have us a check off ever spoken to
Sulu at any point in the other two
movies like directly to I don't realize
the couple of the characters hadn't
really interacted at all there's a lot
of panicky dancers to be a little bit
they were looking at each other don't
give away the secret see sorry yeah okay
looking you guys alright who's next uh
tips for Simon you're kind of living the
dream you get to tell the people in Star
Trek what to do now after all these
years I ask them nicely fair enough but
I don't know like I would have I have
like notebooks full of stuff that I
would like to have done on my favorite
shows and movies and I was wondering is
there anything in Star Trek beyond that
you just always wanted to see in a Star
Trek movie since you were young that you
finally got to do and that was really
important you to add in the movie I
think the kind of the the business of
writing a good story and making sure the
plot were all that kind of superseded
any kind of you know sort of wish
fulfillment we had to start with that
really I mean the whole splitting up the
crew into different little interactive
groups was nice I loved the
relationships in Star Trek and it was
nice to pursue those a little bit more
specifically particularly with bones and
and spun spark and the as Chris
mentioned the scene with
burns at the beginning which is a kind
of vague sort of parallel to the scene
in Wrath of Khan when on Kirk's birthday
when bones and Kirk have that moment
together but it was just the whole thing
you know getting getting the keys to
that Kingdom was was a real joy and and
it was nice to sort of be able to write
our signature underneath the hundreds
and hundreds of signatures that have
gone into writing the Star Trek universe
over the years it was nice to play our
little stamp on that and you know fill
it with little easter eggs only we know
about right here since you guys were
working with Justin this time around
you're a family in a different location
on Los Angeles you kind of have to rally
together a little differently what was
the dynamic working with Justin compared
to JJ I mean Justin has a very different
energy about him I'd say he's a little
more internalized just as a person he's
a little quieter but he's no less
confident he's incredibly gifted as a
visual storyteller and and I think he's
really sensitive to character dynamics
as well he brings a balance of both of
those extremes and he came in on an
already moving train in a lot of ways
you know I mean he didn't have a lot of
time to prep for this film and I think
all of us were incredibly impressed by
his sense of leadership and vision and I
think also it was really great to have
Simon in a position of creative
influence on this film because he was a
tremendous conduit for us early on
before we kind of forged our own
relationships with time with with with
Justin but all in all I mean he was a
really welcome addition and you know I
would say very different from JJ but
also really exciting and really unique
in his own ways and and and reflective
of this experience which was different
and new for us to be away from the past
and the configuration of the last two
films but we all had a great time
working together and we really enjoyed
him and seeing what he was able to
create in the final product is is really
exciting for all of us
back to the front row right here hi my
question is about prop and costume it's
a costume is very seems tight so you had
to skip the lunch sometime or any-any
prop episode it's like a the gadget
looks like a kind of old cellphone for
me right around where I think the pants
were loose a'right guys we are talking
about fantastic this time so much
movement a lot of space in the hips
which I appreciate it um yeah there was
a lot of I don't know how to answer your
question but I will say I'm gonna make
up my own question that answer that so
but there was a lot of you know this is
kind of like the retro super future
version of a Star Trek so it's it's
looking way ahead into what Star Trek
can become and and also having very
specific nods of the past and one of the
very small things is like throughout the
three iterations of the foam so far
there have been a lot of discussions
about colors of yellow for instance for
Kirk shirt and the cut of the of the of
the shirt and this one is a very you
know a specific nod to the to the
original series it's not the kind of
bright fantastic yellow of the of the
first in the second it's this kind of
you know lovely Kirk Ian mustard green
so and I had a lot of lunch
I think Sonya did an extraordinary job
our costume designer one of the things I
was most proud of was the fact that
unlike the previous two films that we
got to do with JJ for whatever reason I
don't know what the reason but the women
the women in and the Starfleet uniforms
in Star Trek beyond all have ranks on
the uniforms which i think is a
fantastic thing at a fan pointed out to
me and I was shocked that that wasn't
the case or one of the first things I
did when I got to Vancouver was going
talk to Sonia about that and she said oh
year don't you worry women will have
ranks they she did a great job that I
bring this let will so bring like a bit
of it's a 60s throwback to
to the costumes but then also making
them slightly knew I had massive envy
for Christine's survival suit yeah but
you get that that just wonderful shade
of blue Carl mm makes you look lovely
ruddy complexion of yours how far do you
see the franchise going now with these
characters and is there any you know
thoughts of the spin-off I with the next
generation so forth and then also just
the fun question of what was the
greatest takeaway for each of you from
this film like what was the best moment
you had with each other or in the Paris
well I hope it goes on for another 50
years you know whether that's we'll keep
going as long as we can until with
holding inappropriate some of us already
are I say me but you know and who knows
actually the thing is about the new
timeline is that Picard Janeway all
those guys they don't exist I'm kidding
I'm kidding okay man would I be in
trouble yeah I hope I mean I hope it
goes under the week there's a new CBS
series starting it's all about you know
the get the galaxy let alone the
universe is a bandless place and there's
so many adventures to be had and as long
as we have this idea that you know what
we might not just all kill ourselves and
die in a big fire we might actually
become slightly more enlightened
slightly more tolerant beings and go off
into space that is a lovely idea that I
think secretly the vast majority of us
want to achieve you know I'm Star Trek
would live forever your longevity
absolutely well I just you know you just
said something about like the next
generation are you calling us old we
just got here totally sure no no here's
cooler
it's good to be present stop wishing
your life away hi Mikey from the Le
Japanese Daily News I just want to touch
very briefly on what you mentioned
earlier the beautiful comment by the way
about ten years not noticing anything
different
I spoke to George this morning on the
way in and he and I were talking about
that's weird cuz he says that he says
that sometimes you've met the man but he
and I were talking about how this the
original Star Trek because you mentioned
they didn't have a lot of special
effects to rely on they rely as much on
social commentary and reflective of the
change at the time to sort of propel
their their story forward in this day
and age I guess the question is what can
the message be now I mean you know the
Oscars so white realm of things and I
look at this cast and what can what can
the message for Star Trek be in 2016 to
help propel it forward like you said
perhaps for another 50 years I mean I
think the message is the same as it was
when it began it's just that we have
more room to explore and express it than
they did at the time you know it's
shocking to me how divisive our culture
has become and I feel like Star Trek
maintains a position of inclusivity and
unity that is as resonant today as it
was in the late 60s you know there this
film in particular explorers that idea
one one side of that being about the
unity and inclusivity and the other
being about breaking that apart and and
I think that's in a way really
reflective of the society we live in
today it's troubling to me on such deep
levels that we've gotten to this point
of unwillingness to see varied points of
view or feelings or opinions or
perspectives and I and I think that Star
Trek remains in a landscape of popular
culture entertainment
something that is a beacon of
inclusivity and and progressive thinking
I think it just takes on different forms
now than it did 50 years ago I think the
film was actually even more opposite
it's become more so in the last even
since we shot it you know the message of
this the social commentary in this
iteration of Star Trek is we're better
together that's what it's about it's
about collectivism and in this era of
brexit and talking about building walls
in certain places you know now more than
ever we should be thinking about the
value of collectivism about cooperation
and you know unity unity that's our that
is that can be and is our strength and
the more fractured we've become the less
secure we all feel you know so you know
the villain in Star Trek is like we
could have called it brexit it's quite a
science-fiction name isn't it
I just saying you know like were you
going to you know in the Star Trek setup
you're going into space and seeing so
many different kinds of species it does
become comically apparent when you look
around the planet earth that we live on
that we do have so much more in common
than we don't you know so it you know
that the little things that seem to
divide us here in our present time seem
even more exaggerated exaggeratedly
small after seeing you know an episode
of Star Trek so we've all got one head
Jun animate let's live together question
Oh
last question okay well I just want to
talk about Sofia for a second because I
thought she was pretty kick-ass amiss
and what what moves did she show you
Simon on any kind of action news
Sophia's incredible she said cuz she's a
dancer and so she's in physically so
adept so she was very up for you know
the physicality of it it's funny I told
this story the other day that when we
dug and I ingested in the writing room
which wanted to create this this very
independent female very resourceful
character on the ultimate surface and we
were trying to get a point we didn't
have a name for us so we used to call
her Jennifer Lawrence in Winter's Bone
that was her that was her long name and
so we go okay so Scottie lands there and
then suddenly Jennifer Lawrence in
Winter's Bone comes out
she fights these guys it started to get
tiring always saying Jennifer Lawrence
and Winter's Bone it's a long name so
then we started calling a J law and then
she became jailor so jailor is basically
named after Jennifer Lawrence and
Winter's Bone but yeah there aren't
enough girls in Star Trek you know Zoey
has a lot on her shoulders
as you know and so we wanted to increase
that and also with Commodore Parris you
know as a figure of extreme Authority
yeah Sofia we all love Sofia don't mean
she's a nutcase in a golden addition to
this this group so she she's awesome
well ladies and gentlemen star trek
behind opens July 22nd a week from
Friday thank you so much
you